it kickstarted some careers and
destroyed others if you choose to appear
nude in a film results May Vary For
Better or Worse the film adaptations of
the erotic romance book series 50 Shades
of Gray gained mainstream popularity
unlike any film of its nature before the
film's overtly sexual content was ripe
for controversy and Intrigue and the
entire Trilogy ultimately made more than
$1 billion at the worldwide box office
50 Shades of Gray stars Dakota Johnson
and Jamie Dornan skyrocketed in Fame
overnight with a press tour full of
uncomfortable conversations and bad
innuendos as daughter to actors Don
Johnson and Melanie Griffith Dakota
Johnson was no stranger to the industry
she began making a name for herself with
minor roles in movies like The Social
Network and 21 Jump Street but her
breakout role in 50 Shades of Gray
accelerated her career she told Vanity
Fair I'm a sexual person and when I'm
interested in something I want to know
so much about it that's why I did those
big naked movies today she's known for
her roles in the Lost daughter and
Netflix's persuasion and is heading her
own production company Tea Time pictures
looking back at 50 Shades now Johnson
elaborated that she doesn't regret
taking on the role Irish actor Jamie
Doran shares a sentiment similar to
Dakota Johnson's regarding the notorious
movies that brought them International
recognition before 50 Shades of Gray
even hit theaters Dornan was already
being addressed by his character name
Christian Gray in real life what would I
get out of
this me speaking to dead Doran admitted
that even years later he still struggles
with being recognized as the character
to this day the actor has since done his
best to separate himself from the
franchise starring in well-received
films such as a private war and Belfast
but he doesn't discount what the movies
have done for his career speaking to
British GQ he explained the thing is
every move I have made in my career post
those films I have only been able to do
because of those films as true as that
statement may be it's up to the
individual as to whether or not Doran
will forever owe the 50 shade's fan base
for his
success no matter what Sydney Sweeney
does the conversation always comes back
to her body and it seems everyone has an
opinion on what the young breakout star
chooses to do with it the Hot Topic
first gained traction with her role as
troubl teen Cassie Howard in the HBO
series Euphoria which frequently
features scenes where the actor is nude
although Sweeney has repeatedly
expressed feeling comfortable on set and
liberated by Cassie sexual nature
viewers have criticized the show and its
creator Sam levenson for portraying
unnecessary nudity of an underage
character no matter your opinion on the
subject Sweeney remains firm in her
belief that she's in control telling the
independent I'm very proud of my work in
Euphoria I thought it was a great
performance but no one talks about it
because I got naked Euphoria won't be
the last project for which Sweeney
participates in a nude scene while the
actor explains to people that she wishes
that appearing nude on screen wouldn't
immediately brand her as a quote sex
symbol she also shared with The
Hollywood Reporter that she had no
intention to stop performing nude as the
need arises perhaps Sweeney's confident
approach to filming nude will help the
TV and film industry begin to have more
open and respectful conversations around
the
subject despite its critical Acclaim the
HBO series Game of Thrones has become
infamous for its heavy-handed depictions
of nudity sex and violence particularly
against female characters one of those
characters was played by Natalie Emanuel
who joined the cast as mande one of
Daenerys targaryen's most loyal subjects
in season 3 by season 7 she became one
of the many actors who appeared nude on
screen during an intimate moment with
co-star Jacob Anderson what
happened many
things many things Emanuel told
Entertainment Weekly that she found
being so vulnerable on screen to be
quite a challenge emanuel's character
was generally well received by viewers
until her graphic death in season 8
which was heavily criticized in terms of
imagery and plot development even so her
acting career took off in the following
years as she landed roles in the maze
Runner and Fast and Furious franchises
however her time on Game of Thrones has
led to assumptions that she's open to
doing nude scenes in other shows on the
rain with Josh Smith podcast she
explained I've had people challenge me
and be like but this part requires that
and I said that's fine if you require
that in the part I don't feel
comfortable doing that level of nudity
luckily it seems that people have been
respectful of that boundary more often
than not when Amilia Clark took on the
role of Daenerys in Game of Thrones her
life changed forever in addition to
quickly gaining worldwide recognition
she became one of the highest paid
actors on television and received
multiple Award nominations all within a
few short years however only 23 years
old at the time and still early in her
career Clark felt blindsided by the
nudity required from her for the show
speaking to Dax Shepard on the armchair
expert podcast she explained that she'd
only been on film sets a handful of
times before she started filming Game of
Thrones so being naked in such a crowded
environment was quite an adjustment for
her eventually however Clark learned to
stand up for herself and become more
comfortable performing in nude scenes
she explained that as the show
progressed she felt more confident
standing up for her own privacy Clark
has had no problem securing jobs since
Game of Thrones and has even had to be
picky with which roles she accepts when
50 Shades of Gray came knocking at her
door with an offer to play the leading
role Clark told The Hollywood Reporter
she turned it down Without Regrets as
she didn't want another intensely nude
role to affect how the public saw her
career when you think of Meg Ryan it's
likely that her widely successful
romantic comedies come to mind whether
she meant to or not throughout the 1990s
Ryan crafted a light-hearted good girl
image for herself with roles in films
like When Harry Met Sally Sleepless in
Seattle and you've got mail however in
2003 Ryan starred in a film unlike
anything she'd done before completely
polarizing her fans in the process in
Jane campion's erotic Thriller in the
cut Ryan received such an adverse
reaction to performing a graphic nude
scene that it ended up being an
unexpected turning point in the actor's
career despite some backlash from
viewers Ryan told the New York Times she
had a great time filming the movie but
was unsure how to proceed with the
Public's response she explained
sexuality in Hollywood is so complex I
don't know if it was Brave or cowardly
of me to sort of Bob and weave around
the issue Ryan stepped out of the
Limelight for a few years before
returning for a series of independent
films following them up with a
directorial debut in
2015 however she told the New York Times
that her separation from Hollywood was
Mutual she now spends her time traveling
writing designing and taking pictures
Hal Berry's career quickly took off in
the 9s with her 1991 film debut in Spike
Le's jungle fever just 8 years later she
received critical Acclaim for her
performance in the HBO biopic
introducing Dorothy Dandridge which gave
her the confidence to take more risks in
2001 her first ever topless scene in the
movie Swordfish made headlines although
Barry claims the rumors that she
received an extra $500,000 for the scene
is false speaking with cinema.com she
explained that she chose to do the scene
because it asserted her character's
independ dependence and control over her
own body in the face of all the scrutiny
she received Barry didn't waver and even
went a step further in her next film
monsters Ball by appearing completely
nude during a love scene again her
nudity was met with controversy but her
performance ultimately paid off when she
became the first woman of color to win
the Academy Award for best actress
curiously her co-star Billy Bob Thorton
did not experience the same level of
scrutiny over his body's presentation in
the film there seems to be a theme of
attractive women exclusively getting the
short end of the stick when it comes to
the Public's response to their
nudity since the Barbie movie crossed
the1 billion Threshold at the worldwide
box office there's been no escaping
Margot Robbie's star power however it
wasn't long ago at all that Robbie was
first getting her start on the
Australian soap opera neighbors her big
break came in 2013 when she appeared in
Martin scorsi The Wolf of Wall Street as
Jordan Belford's wife Naomi the film was
the world's introduction to Robbie and
she made quite the impression although
the famous love scene between the two
coars in which Robbie appears nude did
plenty to capture the audience's
attention it was Robbie's performance
that secured her ticket to mainstream
success we're not going to be friends
initially performing nude didn't come
naturally to Robbie however she told the
New York Times that knocking back a
couple of tequila shots helped get her
in the right heads space to film today
showing some skin doesn't phas her as
much as she told Vanity Fair I don't
really have a whole lot of modesty left
perhaps Robbie's career is proof that
actors are better off bearing it all
from the beginning that way there's
nothing else left to hide few nude
scenes are as iconic as the one in which
Kate Winslet's Rose poses for Leonardo
DiCaprio's Jack for a painting in James
Cameron's Titanic Jack I want you to
draw me like one of your French girls
the iconic scene was actually the first
thing Winslet and DiCaprio filmed
together making for an awkward
experience however it was the Public's
response that really did the most damage
Winslet recalled to the guardian that
her physical appearance and weight were
the subject of a lot of scrutiny and
throughout her 20s she was often asked
to comment on her body in interviews
along with being thrust into the
spotlight Winslet holds some negative
memories from this early time in her
career to her horror fans continue to
present photos from the scene for
Winslet to autograph which she
respectfully declines since Titanic
Winslet has appeared in several nude
scenes in films like the reader
Revolutionary Road little children and
Lee however more than two decades later
the actor continues to deal with body
shaming and she's not shy about how hard
she works to maintain her confidence in
the process she told Vogue people
amongst our own team would say you might
just want to sit up a bit and I'd go why
because of the bit of Flesh you can see
no that's the way it's going to be
evidently Winslet has relied on no one
but herself for the confidence that
solidified her as one of the top actors
of her
generation Helen mirin is a highly
decorated actor who began her career in
theater and film in the late 1960s and
cemented her icon status with critically
acclaimed hit films like 1980s The Long
Good Friday however before her breakout
roles in films like the queen and series
like Elizabeth I the and prime suspect
she was reluctantly viewed as a sex
symbol AS mirin recalled to the Daily
Mail though she lived through the
supposedly revolutionary 1960s she found
men were still largely in charge of the
film industry as a result Miran was put
into a lot of uncomfortable positions
she explained looking back Liberation
did involve a lot of exploitation I
didn't enjoy those scenes but I felt it
was important for me to push myself out
of my comfort zones after her role in
these sexually explicit film Caligula
the press the industry and the rest of
the public were under the impression
that nothing was off limits including
the sexualization of mirin outside of
her character one called her an Amorous
B constrictor others have called her
sensual graceful later in her interview
with the daily maale mirin credited
writer Linda llant with her Liberation
from those misogynist labels as she was
the one to come up with her fully
fleshed out character of DCI Jane
Tennyson and Prime
Suspect if you haven't kept up with with
Daniel Radcliffe's career since his
years portraying the boy who lived in
the Harry Potter film series you may
find his addition to this list
surprising however in an attempt to
break out of the Harry Potter mold
Radcliffe has spent the last decade
taking on drastically different roles
which have included a fair amount of
nudity on both stage and screen from
Radcliffe's perspective the constant
nudity isn't exactly a conscious career
choice he explained to the guardian that
it just happened to work out that many
of the roles that interested him have
required some degree of nudity Radcliff
is well aware of the reputation he's
crafting and he isn't exactly thrilled
about it when it came to a discussion
about a potential nude scene in the
series A Young Doctor's Notebook
Radcliffe pushed back noting that he'd
appeared nude in three different
projects the year before filming the
show as Radcliffe put it to the
publication at some point everyone's
going to start assuming I'm an
exhibitionist as an Italian Australian
actor trying to get work in Hollywood in
the late 80s and early 99s Greta skaki
says going nude was the only way to make
it in the industry for fear of being
labeled as hard to work with otherwise
thus her nude scenes in films like heat
and dust white mischief and shattered
became a part of her identity as an
actor though navigating the environment
on film sets proved problematic speaking
to the Daily Mail she recalled one
conflict she experienced with director
Robert Alman while filming the player
she explained how he had assured her she
would not have to film nude for the
movie but when the day came to shoot her
love scene with Tim Robbins he insisted
that she did she continued to refuse so
they had to film the scene from neck up
to appease her wishes though she's now
in her 60s the promiscuous reputation
still followed scoty for years while no
one asks her to film nude these days she
struggled for years not to be quote
pigeonholed into a particular style of
acting rather than large amounts of
money or fame Sky's years of experience
gave her the confidence and freedom to
turn down lucrative work she deemed
unnecessarily exploitative including the
lead role in the erotic Thriller Basic
Instinct that ultimately went to Sharon
Stone for her part Sharon Stone is well
aware aware of what the role of
Katherine tremell in Basic Instinct did
for her and her career as she reflected
in Vanity Fair in 2021 it's about more
than just a peek up my skirt people wake
up women championed that movie men were
obsessed with a woman who could make it
stop she was their favorite but now only
now do I go to events and there is a
certain respect about that film despite
the film's Legacy the only thing many
viewers talked about was the scene where
Stone spreads her legs while shooting
Stone was told her private area was not
visible but she needed to remove her
underwear regardless during a viewing of
the movie Stone discovered she was lied
to she ultimately decided to keep the
scene in as she felt it was the right
choice for both her character and the
movie as a whole this was only one
instance of many that stone has had to
put up with in her career in her Vanity
Fair article Stone lists her multiple
encounters with harassment from one
director who demanded Stone sit on his
lap to another shaming her and her
mother when Stone refused to act out a
degrading scene still she persisted
writing in the publication that she
worked hard to ensure these challenges
were not in vain since becoming a mother
in 2014 Ava Mendes has taken a step out
of the acting Spotlight with her last
film role being Ryan Gosling's
directorial debut Lost River as she was
getting her start however her looks were
a Hot Topic among many perhaps her brief
semi-nude scenes in her breakout film
Training Day gave people the impression
that Mendes was satisfied with being
regarded as a sex symbol regardless she
started getting a lot of attention after
training day came out Mendes told the
son that she feels capable of exuding
sexuality while acting in roles like
that but she does not see it as her only
Talent she explained I know I can do the
kind of work where people are going to
recognize me just as much for my
determination and sensitivity and humor
as for being sexy ultimately Mendes
hasn't let the scrutiny discourage her
and she's managed to make a name for
herself in both comedic and dramatic
projects for well over a decade no male
Hollywood actor has spent more time nude
on screen than Yan McGregor appearing
full frontal on multiple occasions since
his claimed to Fame in 1996 six is train
spotting as far as McGregor is concerned
it's not as big of a deal as everyone
makes it out to be and he's fine with
doing it if it makes sense however he
told the telegraph that on multiple
occasions he's refused to go completely
nude if he didn't see it as necessary
for a given scene whether he's flashing
his member in velvet gold mine or
pantsless on the toilet and train
spotting his nude scenes are almost
always memorable however most of his
record-breaking on screen nudity comes
from the 1996 erotic drama the pillow
book in which McGregor plays an English
translator Sent to Japan who spends most
of the movie without clothing since
reaching the age of 40 in 2011 McGregor
has been trying to shake off his nudest
reputation by swearing off explicit
scenes altogether especially with
younger actresses while the actor holds
no regrets toward his past nude scenes
he told Express that he wants to ensure
that any women he acts with feel
comfortable and respected on set while
one might assume that having two parents
well versed in the entertainment
industry would have protected a young
Angelina Jolie from the exploitation
often prevalent in Hollywood that
unfortunately wasn't the case when she
was cast in cyborg 2 at the age of 17
when casting a minor certain rules and
regulations are put into place for a
reason but according to Hollywood Gothic
director Michael Schroeder worked hard
to circumvent these rules to realize his
vision for the film The Director even
convinced Jolie to emancipate herself
despite these many red flags Jolie did
end up performing nude for a scene in
the film sadly when she saw the finished
product for the first time it made her
sick this exper didn't deter Jolie from
later appearing nud in movies like The
Good Shepherd Foxfire Taking Lives Gia
original sin and by the Sea however
since her double myectomy Jolie admitted
to being more reluctant like most actors
who have performed nude Jolie will now
only disrobe when the story truly calls
for it throughout her formative years
Brook Shields faced some of the greatest
injustices in the history of the
entertainment industry her mother began
booking her modeling gigs when she was
only 11 months old by age 11 she was
appearing new in her big break film
pretty baby in which she played a
12-year-old sex worker they say that on
the set you felt very uncomfortable
during all this is that true well I mean
I knew it was going to be done in Good
Taste two years later she found herself
subjected to further sexualization
through nude scenes in the Blue Lagoon
this mistreatment continued as she got
older while filming a sex scene in
Endless Love at age 16 director Franco
zepelli even physically hurt Shields to
get the look of ecstasy he wanted from
the actor between these movies and her
explicit modeling ads Shields was
propped up as a child sex symbol in an
interview on her Hulu documentary pretty
baby Brook Shields she reflected that
she's surprised she lived through so
many intense experiences at such a young
age as horrific as her upbringing sounds
Shields doesn't think of herself as
being exploited she has a very practical
outlook on her career telling the New
Yorker I can't be a hypocrite and on the
one hand say I'm going to sell your
stuff and then put it down or say oh I'm
being used either do it or don't do it
you're making money and in most cases
sex
sells french actor Ava Green made her
film debut in Bernardo bertuchi the
dreamers and was instantly on everyone's
radar in the film green plays a
provocative twin who spends most of the
runtime engaging in sexual acts and
appearing nude although the dreamers has
been credited as having kickstarted her
career those close to her weren't too
happy with her decision to star in the
film green told the guardian that her
parents and agent were concerned she
would suffer the same injustices as
Maria Schneider who accused bertuchi of
exploiting her in the sexually explicit
Last Tango in Paris despite the warnings
and the frequent nudity green was eager
to do the film she explained to vulture
I was like I don't care I loved the
story I thought it was just a really
beautiful love story between three
people boobs have never killed anyone
however she went on to describe feeling
shocked after watching the completed
film and has refused to revisit any of
her work ever since the dreamers wasn't
the last time she appeared nude on
screen but green is more particular now
about taking off her clothes when it
came to her role in the 2006 James Bond
film Casino Royale green fought against
a nude scene that would have felt out of
place luckily she has avoided being typ
cast throughout her career taking on
Plenty of diverse rool sense in the '90s
Elizabeth Berkeley was known for her
role as the high achieving
well-intentioned Jesse Spano in the
sitcom Saved by the Bell however when
she left the show to expand her career
into film her big screen debut generated
unexpected controversy in 1995 girls
Berkeley plays an aspiring Vegas
showgirl and performs several sex and
nude scenes the big budget film was the
first of its kind to receive an nc7
rating in the United States and faced
harsh condemnation from critics the
transition from Teen sitcom to erotic
drama proved too jarring for audiences
and many attacked Berkeley for trying
too hard to revamp Her Image 20 years
later director Paul verhoven came
forward to apologize for ruining
Berkeley's career speaking to the New
York Post he took full responsibility
for marring the young actor's reputation
during an anniversary screening of the
film in Los Angeles Berkeley reflected
on her experience saying I had the most
extraordinary experience making the film
which is why when the movie came out it
was more painful than anything you can
imagine she expanded that in the mid 90s
the public was much less Progressive
towards celebrities taking huge creative
risks The Way Berkeley did and being the
subject of such ridicule at such a young
age was very
challenging in season 1 of HBO's True
Detective Alexandra Daario plays the
role of a court stenographer who has an
affair with Woody haralson's detective
Martin Marty Hart in one now famous
scene from the second episode seeing
things Dario's character Lisa undresses
during an intimate moment with Marty
it's a turning point for the show but
didario didn't expect much to come of it
for her as she told kider she did not
find her role in the series particularly
major to Dario's surprise however it was
one of the best things she could have
done for her career the actor a called
my manager calls me in the morning after
the episode aired and she was like the
phone's been ringing off the hook all
morning the phone won't stop ringing and
all of a sudden everyone in town wanted
to meet with me didario revealed that it
was the result of this new found
detention that she booked another major
project from her filmography the role of
Blake in 2015's San Andreas although she
wasn't expecting all the attention
didario feels gratitude for the
opportunity and has expanded into lead
roles on series like the White Lotus and
Mayfair
witches